die eigene verantwortung ist sehr
wichtig und sie wird ja auch von vielen
eingehalten das stört man ja auch fest
man sich ja auch fest dass viele bei dem
sehr diszipliniert bei masken tragen
sehen versteht aber auch in der durch
anderes fest und deswegen ich glaube
gerade wenn man aus risikogebieten kommt
dann sollte es einen verpflichtenden
test geben
jetzt kann man die frage natürlich
stellen ist dass rechtlich alles möglich
sag ich mal ganz einfach wenn es
rechtlich nicht geht dann muss man das
entsprechende recht schaffen das es geht
es ist eine sicherheit für jeden
einzelnen aber es auch eine sicherheit
für die ganze gemeinschaft und die
gesellschaft deswegen plädiere sehr
dafür dass wir die verpflichtenden regen
finden wenn es aus risikogebieten nach
hause geht aber darüber hinaus auch da
muss man nachdenken den anstoß hat der
lauterbach hier gerade auch gegeben wir
müssen eine dritte unterscheidung finden
zwischen den risikogebieten und den
nicht risikogebieten weil es gibt
einfach auch regionen mit regionalen
ausprägungen und wir sollten einen einen
neuen titel eine neue möglichkeit
schaffen dass wir gefahren regionen
definieren unterhalb der risikoregionen
und auch da entsprechende maßnahmen
ergreifen damit wir insgesamt mehr
sicherheit haben ansonsten gehen wir der
gefahr immer näher entgegen dass wir
eine zweite welle bekommen und ich
glaube wir haben heute die chance und
das wissen rechtzeitig etwas zu
unternehmen